>> NEUBERG: Hi, my name is Brad Neuberg. Today,
I want to talk about the SVG Web Toolkit and
some of the work we're doing around Open Web
Advocacy. I want to remind everyone that this
video is public, so make sure if you ask questions
not to say anything that might not be public.
So, I want to keep the talk pretty short,
about 30 minutes, to leave a lot of time for
Q&A. I want to do a lot of demos. You're going
to need to see some interesting use cases
of SVG plus being used with the SVG Web Toolkit.
We'll talk about sort of the Open Web strategy
a little bit and why Google cares about SVG.
You know, why should be invest any time and
energy into this? So the timeline of where
we are I'll briefly compare and contrast SVG
with other things that are out there to kind
of figure out where does this is fit in. And
I want to leave a lot of time for Q&A, and
really depending on where the audience is,
I can crack open the code editor and we can
start to see how you use this. I can talk
about the internals if you want to know what's
going on in the inside of the system. So that's
the general overview. And anytime, please
feel free again to raise your hand and ask
questions. So one thing that's really important
to remember is that there's no plug-ins to
download with this. This is a JavaScript toolkit.
We're kind of cleverly using facilities that
are already present on around 95% of the existing
browsers, so we can instantly get coverage.
And we've targeted a huge slew of browsers,
so IE6, 7 & 8, Safari, Firefox. So you can
start to deploy SVG content across most of
the installed base. And that's really important
and that was really the focus, not to make
some kind of new technology but to really
get to a point to develop this connection
and start using part of the technology to
kind of get out of that chicken and egg problem,
to kind of induce some movement in the system
. I want to say too that even though we've
been working on this, it's been a really amazing
team. I've done a lot of open source, and
when we have anyone who shows up and can contribute
it's amazing. I've had two the best people
I've ever worked with show up and really do
a huge amount of project. James Hight and
Rick Masters, these guys are awesome. They've
been hacking on their weekends. They contributed
a lot of the cool stuff. You'll see we've
got basic font support, video and audio, a
lot of really cool stuff that they've done,
and it's been really amazing. So I want to
start out by showing you...
This is Firefox, and this is the native Firefox
support. And what we see here is just standard
SVG. We've got some images from Flickr. We
can interact with them and scale them. If
you were to crack this open, you'd see pretty
much JavaScript that looks and feels kind
of like the JavaScript when you write JavaScript
for an HTML page. But then we can take this
and going in and out of Explorer. This is
IE-7, and we see the same thing running with
the same degree of fidelity. So that's really
cool, because the developer doesn't even really
know about this SVG Web Toolkit. You just
add this into your page, and at that point
you could start to use the standard as if
it is native and supported. If we were to
crack open this particular sample, what we
would see is a bunch of JavaScript that is
sort of scripting SVG elements. When you use
the SVG Web Toolkit, you'll still feel like
there's a native support. So if we were to
crack this open, you'd see things like, you
know, familiar friends if you've done JavaScript
DOM programming like getElementById. So in
that script for example it might grab a circle
from the page and that just works createElement.
So in HTML you generally have to say createElement
form for example. In this, you have to add
the name and space. We actually added a variable
into the page to make it a little easier.
But there you are. We make a circle. You can
even script the style, and again it looks
and feels like you have native support. So
here we are changing the fill of the circle
to red, and so on. You'll see we have the
DOM. You can manipulate through this at events.
So that's really unique. That's one of the
big things. It not only does SVG support static
SVG but also dynamic because you can really
start to do some interesting things with this.
By default, we only use kind of the magic
that we're doing on Internet Explorer and
we use the native support on Firefox, Safari,
and Chrome. However, you can optionally override
that and have SVG Web to do all of its magic
on those browsers too. Now what's cool about
that is that you can go beyond. So here we
are.
So instead of photos now, now we have videos
that we can manipulate. And keep in mind,
this is Internet Explorer 7. This is running
in a virtual machine. This is the Bruno Trailer
and the new Star Trek Trailer. So that's pretty
cool. Now the video support, that's not natively
supported by any browsers yet. So what's unique
is we can optionally override the native support
in the browser, going away from the default
in order to get those extra features. Now
that's really cool. That means that your project,
you can start by using the native support
in all of those other browsers. But then if
you hit some bug that's in the native implementation
or you want to use something that may not
be as widely supported yet, you can then toggle
on the SVG Web and it will sort of start using
the same magic, and you'll see the same thing.
The JavaScript will interact to the SVG and
it will look and feel like it's really a part
of the browser. This becomes really cool,
because I want to show you fonts, SVG fonts.
Those are natively supported by Safari but
not Firefox yet. So by, in that scenario turning
this on, you can then get that same 95% coverage.
So that's really cool. So that can also act
as a positive spur to help try out some of
the newer things, see how those gel with developers
and then the other browsers can sort of natively
fill those in. Just before I jump on, any
question so farm what you've seen? No questions?
Yes, Romy?
>> ROMY: Does--is this using Flash?
>> NEUBERG: Yes. So, Romy's question is, is
this using Flash? On the inside, we use a
slew of different tricks. So we used Flash
to do the displaying. We used something called
Microsoft Behaviors to actually kind of get
some of the magic around the JavaScript type
of work. The reason we choose Flash is that
it has a 97% install base. So like I said,
we kind of cleverly used various facilities
that are already present on the browser so
the users don't have to install anything.
So right, the actual rendering when SVG Web
does its magic is Flash. We used Flash 9 and
4 which was the one that has... We're not
using Flash 10 yet because it doesn't have
as much coverage. Any question? So right,
like I said, you can use this--this is the
whole reason we did this. Today, you can use
this to deploy real content across 95% of
the existing web. So that was the goal. And
it's as easy as dropping a script source into
your page. When we get to the Q&A, I can go
a little bit more into what configuration
of deployment looks like, but basically you
add a script to your page. And at this point,
we're supporting a lot of the SVG 1.1 standard.
There are some, you know, there are some areas
that aren't covered. And there's a few areas
where you have to just slightly change what
you're doing. But in general, it's a tremendous
amount of, it just feels like native support.
Now there's actually two ways to embed. We
support using the object tag, it has a syntax
similar to this. And then we also support
dropping directly into normal HTML. So you
could drop this in the normal HTML. It doesn't
have to be XHTML. It could just be a normal
plain old, plain vanilla HTML. And the way
you do that is we actually--an HTML file allows
this, by the way. You use a script tag and
you set the mime type, and then you just drop
your SVG right into the page. So that can
really be nice for certain scenarios because
you might have normal HTML. Your JavaScript
in the page can still manipulate this. You
can integrate with HTML a little better. So
those are the two deployment options we support
right now. So I want to show you a couple
of cool demos. These Tetris demo is actually
written where it's embedded directly into
a normal HTML page. And I'm going to show
this, this is a Safari, but it's actually
overriding the native renderer, and we have
Tetris. This is fun debugging this actually,
it's like I get to play Tetris while I'm working.
It's just nice. And here we are. So again,
pretty straightforward stuff. That's just
great. It just looks and feels the same. This
is a really cool one. One of the volunteers
in our community put this together. One of
the unique things about SVG and I'll now go
over when do you want to use the SVG versus
Canvas and where does it make sense? One of
the real nice things about SVG is it can make
real sense for sort of when you want something
that's more than an image. And what you're
going to see for this, this is a population
pyramid that's pulling population statistics
for different countries. And in real time,
you can translate all the texts on the page
to different languages, into Russian, into
Cyrillican, into German. That's really cool
because at the end of the day SVG is just
text which is really nice too because it's
really easy to make a PHP script or an App-engine
script that just shoots out SVG that might
have data embedded into it. This is a nice
use case. This is actually Safari with its
native support. We see the two different population
demographics. And I'll actually do all the
toggling in IE so you can get to see how this
guy actually works. So the monitor is a little
small but right here we have a language toggle.
Let's change this into Russian. You will see
that it has now been translated into Russian.
Now what's really cool again because this
is more than an image. It's text. You can
do things like that. You can also interact
with it. So, outside of this is, is a normal
HTML page. And as we go over this, we have
directly embedded SVG into the page using
that script tag approach you saw. So something
like this. I know the volunteer who created
this, he used an existing kind of demo. He
was able to put this together really fast.
So running in IE. I'd like to call this one,
I'd like to call--this is the hello world
of vector graphics. If you've ever... Ray
Flat, he knows this one. The reason I want
to show you this one is one of the things
that makes SVG unique is the fact that it's
resolution independent. You are able to give
one size. And whether you are looking at an
iPhone or you're looking at a 40-inch monitor,
what you're dealing with can scale and still
stay beautiful and still stay legible. So,
this is the tiger. This is the hello world
of vectors. I'm just showing you, we're going
to zoom in. This is actually known as the
view box. By default, an SVG image will just
display how it needs to display. But you can
have more control of it of what's called the
view box to say, you know. Actually, fit it
into something really, really big so it's
going to zoom out or something really, really
small. So you can actually animate that and
do interesting things. Here right now, we'll
just toggle the button to change the view
box. So notice as we zoom in, it doesn't pixelate.
It stays beautiful. So you can imagine on
an iPhone which has good SVG support as the
user pinches and zooms in, the text, the images
is going to stay legible and nice. So, fonts.
We've got basic font support. And what's really
unique about SVG fonts is they're just text.
I like to call them, they're a cut and paste
technology. And I'll show you a little snippet.
Safari natively supports them. Let me show
what that looks like. This right here is actually
the DroidSans fonts which come on the Android
phone, which is a nice font. It's actually
open source. And we just ran it through a
little converter and turn into SVG font which
is just plain text you drop in your page just
like you would an image. Here it is natively
supported. But then, we come over to IE. And
we see the same thing with the same fidelity.
So what's really--again, when it comes--again,
keep in the back of your mind, 95% coverage
drop a JavaScript library into the page. Now,
this isn't just showing, "Hey, this is cool
stuff you can use five years from now," you
know. Yes, Ray.
>> RAY: Are those fonts rendered a sort of
shape fills or are they rendered using the
full on rendering capability of the browser
with like clear typed on windows and so on
and so forth?
>> NEUBERG: So the question is are these fonts
being rendered as shape fills or are they
going into the sort of full OS support? So
SVG fonts are interesting. They are--you can
think of them more as the application letter.
They--you define a glyph. Like you say, "Here's
the letter A." And then you say, "And here's
the SVG commands to draw that." So, it's not
dropping down into a native OS support. And
we only support a subset, we only say, "You
can have a path statement." So, right, you're
not going to get any sort of acceleration
or other things that might be at the OS layer.
>> RAY: This sub-pixel rendering that's really,
you know, that's really....
>> NEUBERG: Right.
>> RAY: You know, that's one of the--that's
one of the arguments for, I think, a Canvas.
>> NEUBERG: Yeah.
>> RAY: HTML 5, does have that kind of font
rendering fidelity?
>> NEUBERG: So, the question is getting the
sub pixel rendering is one of the arguments
for the HTML Canvas? Yeah. So there's pros
and cons. So the nice thing about this is
it's something you can start using. Personally,
I really hope this sort of CSS way of importing
a true-type file or open type file. I hope
that in the long run, it becomes the standard
way to do things, but it could be--it could
be awhile. So, good question. I'd like to
say, you know, when would you use this? I
want to you show you a sample of when this
makes sense. One of the nice things about
SVG is you can start combining these things
together. You'll see some animations, some
fonts, some filters, so whenever you want
to start combining these things together,
that's when it makes sense. If you just want
a nice headline, this is probably overkill.
And you probably want to use something called
like Cipher or something like that. So when
you want to start doing fancy things, I'll
show you a good demo in a little bit where
you're combining these things in an interesting
way, then it--then it starts making sense.
Oh, and I also want to say of course the iPhone
supports SVG fonts. Yes.
>> You know, what about Android? Can it support
it?
>> NEUBERG: Yeah, Android is an unfortunate
story. Android is something we can't support.
It doesn't have--they use a Web Kit, but they've
clipped out a lot of Web Kit extensions. There's
some cool stuff from Web Kit that's simply
clipped out. Plus, there's no Flash, so there's
not much that we can do. It's an unfortunate
situation. So, I'm going to have this load
up an SVG font demo on the iPhone. I guess
we don't have a camera. I might have to pass
this around the audience, huh? I hope we can
keep this up on the screen. You probably can't
see it. We kind of see exactly the same font.
And of course, this really does support as
you zoom in and out. And so I want to give
this to you,
so feel free to hand it around, and zoom it
in and out. So like I said, they're really
straightforward, they're just text. They're
just a bunch of glyphs, right? If a glyph
name equals "A", you need to find A, you give
your data. You can technically actually support
full SVG, and it will really support the path
statement, which gets you pretty far right
now. And right--if you're rendering a whole
document, or you want something with that
kind of sub-pixel, you're not going to get
that right now. So, we fully support you scripting
with JavaScript, but there's--there's a couple
of downsides with that that's really, really
good for more experienced developers. We also
support basic animation. This is also known
as Smile. But we support basic Smile. So this
is--this can be really nice for more beginner
developers. It also actually allows us to
do some performance improvements when you're
actually using SVG Web because we don't have
to do as much talking back and forth, so you
can get better performance. But here's an
example of that. I'm going to show you a video,
and you can actually add these, all sorts
of tags. So, right here, we're adding a video
tag. I've kind of clipped off some of the
attributes so it can fit. And then we say
animate and it's really straightforward. We're
saying animate the width from 400 to 300 pixels,
start at two seconds after the document's
loaded. Go for five seconds. And then when
it's done, freeze at the final state. It's--I
mean, you could do that with JavaScript. And
that's--it's pretty nice to be able to do
with the simple tag especially again if you
have some PHP, or an App Engine, that's spitting
out some code, that can just add it in for
like animated menus or something. So this
one--this is actually combining those animation
tags along with SVG audio. So there's no JavaScript,
you see a little, little scimitar shimmering
things. So there's no JavaScript in this page,
it's just those animation tags. I didn't have
the--I can--I think Rick Masters might have
added that--the music. I think it's like open-source
music or something. So, again, if you were
to crack this one open, you could see a bunch
of anime tags. You'd see--but one of the cool
things about SVG is you can group things together.
Just like in Photoshop, you know, you can
grab all these things, group them together,
treat them as a unit. Same thing in SVG, we
can actually have some quite complicated drawing
commands for the scimitar which might have
been exported from Illustrator. And we can
say as a group, you know, animate this from
this exposition to this exposition with a
single tag and then start this music when
things happen. And again one of the cool things
is you can animate all sorts of things. So
here we are. This is actually kind of a test
page. You see various different things there
and then the jerkiness because I'm playing
this in a virtual machine instead of Macro
SX (ph). So, you have those different squares
that are moving based on the anime tags. Of
course, you can also say not just on duration,
but you can say start or stop something when
you have an event that happened such as a
clip. And we are restarting. So that's still
pretty experimental but we have quite a lot
already in. Now remember, I mentioned how
some of this stuff comes together when you
combine them together. We're hosting in the
fall the SVG open conference here at Google.
And here's the banner that they have made.
And this is a really nice kind of showing
everything coming together. This is IE7 again.
You'll see certain things fly in. The screen
is a little dark. So the contrast isn't correct.
But over on the upper right, you see SVG open
net, that's even more yellow on my screen.
That's a font with the blur filter on it.
You see gradients. Everything that flew in
it's just these simple anime tags. And this
was a great use case. This file was written
by someone who's another not a programmer,
they're graphic designers. But they were able
to use Illustrator and Inkscape, put it together
and then put these things together pretty
quickly. So, why SVG? Why does Google care
about SVG? So one of the things that's important
is SVG is sort of a part of the HTML 5 family
of technologies. I'll touch on that a little
bit more but HTML 5 talks about here's how
you embed SVG into a normal HTML page. One
of the things I really respect about the HTML
5 process is you need to show that there's
market demand. You need to show that there's
some valid use cases for something to make
it an HTML 5. I like that process. So, the
SVG folks showed, here are some valid use
cases, where this is important. So, it's--as
a part of the HTML 5 initiative and Firefox
3.5 actually has support for this, it's not
turned on by default yet. But it's probably
gonna come soon. What's exciting about that,
in the past you had to use X HTML which like,
0.000001 percent might have used to use SVG
and now you can drop it into the 99.9 repeating
bar that most of the content is under and
that's nice, kind of freeze things up. One
of the really unique things about SVG is it
is searchable, now this doesn't make sense
when you have a tiger illustration but when
you have an electoral map of the U.S., with
all the states, such as Wikipedia, and I'll
talk about Wikipedia in a bit. We're talking
about--it make sense when you got a medical
diagram, you've now opened up a lot of interesting
content, especially expert oriented content,
that can now be searched. And it's in our
interest to make sure the web doesn't become
big binary blobs. And that makes sense for
certain use cases like video. But it's nice
when we can prevent that, you know, and have
open searchable things. I already mentioned
Market Demand. One of the unique things about
SVG that it uses existing web skills, so when
we get to Q&A I can crack open one of these
things, but again, it pretty much feels like
you're interacting with a DOM and JavaScript,
HTML, and so on, CSS. What I like to say is,
these are view source technologies; it's already
been great getting these things. I always
look for test cases and I learned just by
view source, you know. That population demo,
if that had been a big binary blob, I could
have been, like, "Hey, that's really cool,
how did you that?" And they may not have told
me. But I was able to crack it open and say,
wow, that's an interesting, and it's nice
and I learned. So, these are cut and paste
technologies, just like the YouTube embed
script. So, if you see something that you
like and of course, you always have to respect
Copyright but that's inherent in HTML already.
Then you can learn and if some things open,
you could easily use it, like that open font.
That DroidSans font is open source. So, if
you like it, you could cut and paste it, add
it into your file and go forward. One of the
really cool things, is that--it's really server
friendly. Yes, you can have PHP that spits
out some binary flash or something like that.
It's not easy. It's really easy to do that.
Especially now, the way that we allow to directly
embed into normal HTML. We use it, we use
it, for example, and presently, in Google
maps and in our internal closure, we use it
as sort of one of our drawing surfaces when
there's native support. And finally, one the
really key use cases, is import and export.
When you're dealing with assets, when you
have like that map of the U.S. and I want
to show you a really cool demo. This shows
Canvas being used with SVG. You don't want
that to be 10,000 lines of JavaScript that
calls for drawing a map of the U.S., you know.
What you want is you want to import that resource
to SVG and then add whatever magic on top
of that, using Canvas. That's where that starts
to make sense. So, I wanted to quickly touch
on the timeline, actually, there's couple
of details I didn't mention. One is the library
of 60k. So, if you have native support, you
actually don't take that hit, but that's pretty
nice. You have a lot of support in 60k. Right
now, we have an Alpha build, Wikipedia, they
have a monster repository of SVG, they're
gonna use SVG web to present that stuff to
Internet Explorer, I'm working with them on
a tool for that. The big focus right now is
performance and bug fixes and community support;
sort of people are starting to use this. In
the fall, the first week of October, we're
hosting the SVG open conference here at Google.
There's gonna be lots of--the Raphael folks
are gonna be there, Jojo of GFX, and Gavin
is involved with some of those folks. There's
gonna be a lot of really interesting presentations
and we're also going to kind of more formally
unveil the work we've been doing with this
along with others outside. And after that,
I originally wanted to have a date of release,
I think it's gonna be more of an early access
release. And of course, more advocacy, in
terms of the timeline. You know, so, I've
mentioned this open web strategy. When we
started our open web advocacy group, we're
like, what the heck is this? What does it
mean to do open web advocacy and we took as
our goal, we want to help accelerate the rate
at which developers can actually use this
stuff. We saw ourselves as a bit more of sort
of cross browser team, and one of the ways
we sort of mapped out that, how you do this
is we came up with what we called, communication
credibility and capability. So, we said, capability
is just actually being able to use something,
you know. Where can I use CSS 3 for example;
like getting that capability across enough
browsers that developers feel comfortably
using it? So, native browsers support all
the great work that the web kit and the Chrome
teams have been doing, in terms of getting
good browser support and then JavaScript tool
kit. That's my background and that's where
I can help contribute through JavaScript shims.
They can help get the capability up faster,
so we don't have to wait so long. And then,
credibility, this is something that more propriety
plug-ins have done very well. They'll make
claims like, you can run this, you know, more
than 90% on the web. We wanted to come up
with similar numbers and then use those JavaScript
tool kits to help that. So, we can now say,
you can use this almost--almost on a 100%,
we say 95% to be conservative, that's up there.
Without the JavaScript tool kit, it's more
like 30%. So, developers, when they numbers
like that feel more comfortable starting to
use something. And then, getting traditional
advocacy wins. And so, Wikipedia or folks
that embrace using this and says, "Hey, we've
done this, and here's how we're doing it and
here is how you can do it too." And then,
finally communication, blogging, articles,
presentations, so that's kind of how we think
about what the heck we're doing on the open
web advocacy team when we started. So, before
I jump on, any questions about what you've
seen so far? Any questions over VC? No questions?
All right. So, I want to quickly compare and
contrast--I'm--I'm going to skip HTML 5, because
I already spoke, about how this fits to HTML
5. It's--it's not necessarily a part of the
spec, but the spec says, here's how you embed
SVG, in the normal HTML, and that is major
new feature of the HTML 5. How does fit with
Canvas? Well, I want to show you a really,
really cool nice shot of the Canvas and SVG
tags that Mozilla did. But I think really,
it help shows the various strengths of the
two technologies. So, this is the--this doesn't
use SVG web at all, this uses a native support.
This is a download tracker, for the Mozilla
downloads. What you see on the left is a map
of the U.S.; on the right you see the browsers
kept open at persistent connection over to
the server, in real time, to find out who's
downloading something. And then you see, it
might be a little small unfortunately, do
you see those little red dots that are appearing
on top? Do you see as I zoom in, do you see
them appearing and disappearing? The map is
SVG. The red dots are Canvas. The red dots
aren't interactive, SVG excels when you want
to do light interactivity, in a user interface
oriented matter. Because we don't need that,
the Canvas dots, that's a really good use
case of Canvas. So, this is a nice sort of
match up to show the technologies together,
and so, one of the--of the strengths and which
also can be one of the weaknesses. You have
to choose your battles, SVG is like HTML,
you get a DOM, when you add something, when
you add a rectangle or a square, it's an object,
you have a rectangle or a square on the page.
That could be really nice, because it means
that you can add event handling easily. It
retains its identity; you can enumerate all
those things. You can really do interesting
things with that. Things like this, for example,
adding an event handler is very straightforward.
Now, if you're doing a side scrolling game
that has no mouse interactivity and uses the
keyboard to jump back and forth, you don't
want that trait, you want Canvas; you want
to just blip pixels. So, in graphics parlance
these are known as a retained API and an immediate
mode API. And in general, you have, you choose
the right one for your project and you--if
you choose an immediate mode API and you really
wanted the retain mode, that means you're
rebuilding all event detection and hit detection,
you're building the tree yourself, that's
a lot of code, it's a lot bugs, it's a lot
time spent. So, SVG has a retain mode API,
yeah, and Canvas is immediate mode. And so,
here we see, SVG in that case is more high
level, which depending on your needs, helps
you or hurts you and Canvas is more low level,
and again, that can be a pro or a con. So,
when you start a project, you ask yourself
things like, do I need import and export?
Am I dealing with assets? Do I have tiger
illustrations? So I have, you know, things
like that, the SVG excels with that. It's
very easy to make a user interface, if I had
to do the population demo that you saw, that
would be challenging with Canvas, you can
do it. But it's not really a great use case.
Interactive, especially when you start getting
lightly interactive, SVG really is good at
that. Medium animation, and by the way, that's
also gonna be true for Canvas. Flash is fast,
it's very fast. Both Canvas and SVG, there's--depending
on the implementation there's a performance
differential of 10% to 30% between each other,
and that's probably, that's narrowing over
time, to probably about 15%, but both of them,
if you throw a lots of objects on the page,
ten thousand bouncing balls, you're gonna
bring both of them to their knees. So, choose
your battles. And again, you have a tree of
objects. Canvas really excels when you're
doing--when I say non-interactive, the keyboard--if
using the keyboard for a game, for example.
That's not really interacting with the stuff
that's on the page. It's kind of outside of
that and so that's a good use case. I want
to say SVG has accessibility written into
it. It's a little bit more complicated of
a story, but you can make your file accessible.
None of the screen readers yet read it, but
when they do, if you write your things right,
they will be able to correctly say, this is
a scimitar, this a population graph. So, there
you go. Any questions about pixel? I want
to say one thing that's really important is
that both Flash and Silverlight have arrived
at the fact that they need both. Which is
actually true, you know, sometimes in the
open source world we can have like Gnome versus
KDE battles or you know, we always like civil
wars. But you actually need both. And personally,
Canvas is very important and so is SVG. But
the corollaries are showing up on the other
side, Flash 11, Flex 4, is going have something
called FXG which is basically SVG with, you
know, global replace, change a couple of names.
And then of course, there's a Flash Drawing
API. Which corresponds quite strongly to the
Canvas AP1; that's what we use internally,
in order to do a lot of the work. Silverlight
of course has XAML, again which is mark-up.
You have a circle tag and so on. And then
there's a Drawing API. So those are gonna
have both, you know, we don't want to walk
around with just one arm, you know, we want
to be able to have both in the open communities
as well. So, here's the project page. I'm
gonna jump into Q&A; we're going to do Q&A,
one second. And I'll take questions, we've
got about 15 minutes. So, depending where
the audience is at, maybe that's enough, maybe
you want to crack open some code, know more
about the internals. Yeah, you have a question?
So, the question is, it sounds like I said
that there's not much performance difference
between Canvas and SVG. So, what would be
the benefits of Canvas? I didn't say that,
there is a performance difference. Last I
saw, someone found about a 20% performance.
I saw a study about a year and a half ago,
20% to 30% percent. Again, neither of them
is a silver bullet. Like I said, you have
to choose what you're doing. If I were doing
a side scrolling game--if I was doing a non-interactive
graphic visualization with 10,000 data points,
I would use Canvas. It's exactly, it's exactly
when--it's when their benefits become their
cons. So, when I have--if I wanted to have
an interactive population graph, with all
those lines, that would be a nightmare to
build it on Canvas. I have to rebuild the
whole bunch of facilities that I get for free.
Yeah. Yeah, when I don't need to interact
with all the stuff on the screen and if you
have a tremendous data set, actually you're
gonna bring both of them to their knees currently.
But if you have a very, very large data set,
I probably wouldn't want the bookkeeping of
SVG with 10, 000 data nodes. But if I wanted
something that's search engine friendly, spit
out by PHP, so and I think at this point developers
need to know when to use either one or how
to do it. Any question? Oh, that's a good
one.
>> So, any hopes of shimming out Canvas for
us as well?
>> NEUBERG: So, that's already handled by
the excellent Excanvas library, Emil Eklund,
Erik Arvidsson, that's using VML under the
covers. I know they've been--they've been
exploring other renderers, like Silverlight.
It's a mature project at this point; it's
been out for a few years. They--they were
supporting a huge amount of the API. I know
there's some newer things that--are you looking
at supporting those things or...? Actually
do you want to answer the question? Why don't
you come? Because it's recorded. We've got
one of the creators of the Excanvas library,
which is really is, like the sister project
of SVG Web.
>> So, Explorer Canvas currently supports
most of the Canvas specification, there are
some newer additions though like saving image
data and clipping and a certain gradient support
that is very hard for us to support with VML,
which is the back end of the Explorer Canvas
emulation.
>> Well, you know, rendering quality is kind
of crappy especially with like curved lines
and things, so, I'm just wonder if we get
a higher fidelity Canvas by using different
rendering technology?
>> We've been exploring that and we currently
have an alternative renderer using Silverlights.
We have not looked into using Flash at the
moment. But maybe we could combine our forces
and do that in the future.
>> NEUBERG: That--that's interesting. I know
that the Silverlight work is really interesting.
Yeah, maybe, you know, especially we've done
a lot of work around eking out performance
of the Flash JS Bridge, that might be useful.
And especially if you can combine, I know
Ray Cromwell has done a lot of cool work,
if you can introduce batch operations, you
know, maybe just slightly add a couple of
methods saying, you know, for example, last
week, I implemented suspend withdraw which
has helped performance hugely and this week,
I'm doing document fragment. So, these are
all essentially batch operations which would
really help the performance. The Canvas AP
doesn't currently have those in them. But
if you could add them [laughs]. You know,
start batch, end batch and then Ray Cromwell
has done some good work and that could help
performance. Which you're right, there is--there
is an impedance mismatch. We have that over
in the Flash line too, you know, we have Bezier
curves, or some certain things, we've been
able to patch over a lot of those. There are
a few things we can't support like smaller
than one pixel, line drawing and stuff. But
it's, you know. Has that answered your question,
though? So, any other questions? Yeah, uh-huh.
So, the question is how is the performance
over the Flash JS boundary for SVG web especially
for event handling? The first thing to say
is a shim will never match a native performance.
This is a temporary solution, unfortunately
on the web temporarily means like three years,
you know, if you're lucky actually. So, you
know it will always be less. But I've been
able--I mean, it's a real focus of mine and
I've had lots of performance sort of sessions
where I focus on performance, one of the things
that I am looking at now. I've been able to--for
the last two weeks, get a hundred percent-fold
speed improvement with some of the things
I've been doing. And I'm hitting some other
things. So, it's okay right now. If you may
have seen some of the samples loaded very
fast and some of them like the tiger and getting
more complicated, it can take a little while.
But I don't think we hit the ceiling of--of--of
how you can get performance faster and I'll
give one sample of that. The Flash JS boundary
is always going to be slower, there are other
possibilities, one is when you batch things
up. So, combining everything with the suspend
re-draw if I'm affecting 500 elements on the
screen like the population graph, I turn that
into one Flash JS call, that says here's what's
to change. Other things I'm exploring are
if you use Smile, if you programmatically
create a Smile element, do the animation tags
and send them over. At that point, everything
lives in the rendering engine and you could
potentially get very fast performance. So,
there are all sorts of things I'm exploring
along this continuum. Is that--and I haven't
yet had a use case that had tremendous numbers
of events arriving from the other side. So,
I haven't seen a bottleneck yet on that one.
Yeah, I haven't seen a bottleneck yet on that
but I'm always looking for good use cases
that help find bottlenecks because it helps
me to optimize.
>> Uh-huh, I got that right. Yeah, I had--one
of the question which was about normalizing
SVG support across browsers, you know, for
all the browsers except for IE, actually we
have SVG and you've done a lot work presenting
a normal API. Do you have this idea of like
bridging? So, for example, if a browser doesn't
support Smile, can you, you know, implement
Smile for that browser of it is just like
you wanted to drop into Flash as quickly as
possible?
>> NEUBERG: Yeah, I don't have it in that
fine grained, you know, I started out with
the whole complicated capabilities type of
thing and I was like, "I'm going to make this
the simplest as I can until I see actually
what developers want." So, at this point,
it's the binary decision. You can drop a metatag
into your page and the metatag says, you know,
"Name equals spg.render.forceflash," that's
true or false and that will force Flash for
all browsers. You can also overwrite on URL
which can help when you're testing. I will
probably at some point introduce the ability
to target some specific user agents. I've
been surprised--Safari's SVG support is excellent,
so is Operas, Firefoxes, hmm. So, I might
make it possible for you to say, use SVG web
on IE and Firefox and let Safari and Chrome
do their thing natively in Opera. So, no,
the answer to your question right now is no.
It's a binary decision. And again, remember,
I want to--I want to really avoid this--the
laser focus, this provides dynamic and static
SVG support. I don't want this to turn this
into an uber-tool kit that tries to be a complete
emulation of the entire standards based web.
And even--I'm not even that wedded to standards,
it's more, you know, what--at this point,
we're going to start experimenting for Java
with an extra add on library at some point
to make using SVG much more terse. So, huh,
Ray?
>> RAY: On the SVG text fonts what kind of
support is there for complex script?
>> NEUBERG: That's a good question. So, the
question is when it comes to the SVG web fonts,
what kind of support is there for complex
scripts? I didn't build the SVG font support,
Rick Masters did. So, I'm not as like deep
into the details. SVG fonts have a lot of
support for quite a lot of control over like
the curning, going pretty deep and it is internationalized.
I would suspect--I don't--we obviously don't
have left or right to left control with what
we have now. Since everything is just a path,
I'm sure you could define, you know, here's
the--here's a Thai character. But I don't
think it would dynamically go right to left
if that was needed. So, you could pro--you
could display internationalized glyphs because
they're under your control but, you know,
top to bottom, right to left, is that kind
of what you have in mind?
>> RAY: Well, more things like automatic signatures
and like mixed tools and like that kind of
things and stuff.
>> NEUBERG: We--yeah, we--we--so, it comes
to the animation video, we hit the low hanging
fruit on a lot of this.
>> RAY: Sure.
>> NEUBERG: The SVG 1.1 support of the core
is quite strong. But for those kinds of low
hanging fruits we're like, [sighs] we're so
close and they're really cool. So, we hit
probably like the 80%. But when it comes to
more advanced, that's going to have to grow
over time. And by the way, I don't think if
you noticed, this is a very iterative approach,
right? But when it get--that's always been
the idea. Can you get a usable set of this
stuff that you can use in a production environment?
Just like what we did with CSS. You get enough,
solve real use cases and you grow from there.
And you hit enough browsers that folks can
actually use this stuff. Hey, let's take one
more question or not. Okay, everyone, thanks
so much.